نعود الى الملف السوداني وهذه الصور
والمشاهد تظهر معنا ايضا تعزيزات من قبل
الجيش السوداني ودبابات للجيش السوداني
مترجعه الى العاصمه السودانيه نتابع معكم
اذا هذه المشاهد وهذا المقطع المتداول
لتعزيزات ودبابات للجيش السوداني المتجهه
الى العاصمه السودانيه حيث كل الاعين
اليوم على العاصمه السودانيه تصاعد حده
الاشتباكات في ظل الهدنه الهشه التي من
المفترض ان تنتهي اليوم مع مرور اثنتين
وسبعين ساعه بعد هدنه العيد اذا من قوات
ومعدات عسكريه ودبابات للجيش السوداني
تتجه الى الخرطوم هذا الفيديو المتداول
الان نتابعه معكم في ظل الحديث عن ترجيحات
التصعيد اليوم خصوصا مع ان عمليات الاجلاء
ما زالت مستمره وتمضي بكثافه من كافه
الدول وح رجحت الكثير من المصادر وعدد من
المراقبين للوضع العسكري والسياسي في
السودان بان عمليات الاجلاء هذه وهي
تحذيرات من احتمال توسع الصراع في ضوء
تسارع عمليات الاجلاء والخروق المستمره
للهدن طبعا هذه اخر المشاهد والفيديوهات
التي وصلتنا ونعرضها لكم في سياق هذه
التغطيه المستمره والمباشره على شاشه
العربيه فيديو جديد قوات مستمره في توسيع
نطاق تامين الخرطوم من قبل الجيش السوداني
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات